hi I'm Dan hi I'm Philip and we're here
to help you pronounce some words from
The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt it's not as
difficult as it may seem
Skelly 7 out of 10 7 out of 10 Skelly's
4 out of 10 oh god that's going
backwards ok Skellig 8 out of 10 day
Skellig a Skellig is an RP kill ago with
many islands and it has arts Gaelic as
the main island
Skellig a now go far
9 out of 10 I would say nine out of 10
NACO far Nagas far Maggie far is the
ship of the Wild Hunt which is built
from the fingernails of the Dead Naugle
far crack and crazed seven out of ten
seven out of ten crash uncrate two out
of ten crack some crates yeah nine out
of ten no you had a ten oh I was being
silly
yeah I'm kite and he's the clan leader
of the kite clan of Arts Kelly ha I'm
Craig fine seed he can I get 0 o 0 and
said get out of 10 10 yeah and said and
that's how the elves of the world of The
Witcher call themselves and say seasons
it's Dijkstra yep perfect
oh my god I got a perfect yes that's
amazing Sigismund Dijkstra Sigismund or
Dijkstra is a spy of Fredonia and you
will meet him in wild hat
Sigismund Dijkstra eridan Brack glass
what a lot of temp
okay headed in black glass and he's a
very very dangerous person that you will
meet in the Wild Hunt everything black
glass Amir vah Amaris dice when a done
in carne a more rude I think an oath
guard II would be executed by now any of
our em rice tight when Adam in Karev
motherhood is the emperor of nilfgaard
and the last part actually meant the
flame dancing on the grave of its
enemies
mmm rice died when a done in care Abner
would CD Projekt five out of ten five
out of ten CD Projekt six out of ten
sugar project two out of ten Janet say
they play act and that's the company
making Witcher wild hunt say they
project but we are not mad if you just
call a CD Projekt thank you for joining
us we hope you've learned how to
pronounce some words from The Witcher 3
Wild Hunt out on the 19th of May for
PlayStation 4 Xbox one and PC and don't
worry you will still enjoy well and even
if you can't pronounce everything
perfectly